high scores are serious business some
people even use hacking to stay on top
that's why when rock band fours January
update hits it'll wipe the slate clean
resetting the games online leaderboards
Harmonix knows this is a bummer for
anyone legitimately playing the game
well but says it's a necessary move the
team said we know that many of you have
worked hard to climb the leaderboards
and that wiping your scores sucks that
said these changes will ensure that in
the future you won't be unseated from
the top spot by someone using an exploit
and if we do discover an issue down the
road we can address it much more quickly
and easily it might hurt now but nipping
this problem in the bud means no one can
hack out your perfect run of Jack
White's Lazzaretto and this only affects
online scores all those personal best
runs on your console are safe you can
keep playing through all the changes the
January update brings for all the news
you need on music and rhythm games stay
tuned to gamespot and keep on rockin in
the free world